so to me this this quest that I'm a part
of it relates to thinking about the
early universe that's the very big it
relates to thinking about the
microscopic structure that's the very
small but it most of all relates to
asking the question of how does how do
how does a complex world come out of
simple laws and and that I think is the
most profound answer to why this is
worth doing using these tools to share
mi t--'s perspective mi t--'s
understanding mi t--'s vision mi t--'s
knowledge in a way that will empower
people whom I will never meet to change
the world boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
sake on we are at MIT s open learning in
Cambridge Massachusetts we're now gonna
be talking about all things physics all
things open learning I'm very excited to
have dr. Krishna rajagopal joining us on
the show hello
hi there thank you so much for coming on
huge shout out to Sanjay Sarma for
introducing us that are very grateful
and this is such a cool place we just
had her Dina on the show as well we love
open learning what you guys are doing
here and for those that don't know
krishna's background he's dean for
digital learning and professor physics
at MIT his focuses range from quarks in
the microseconds old universe to sharing
the best of MIT knowledge and
perspectives with learners around the
globe and you can check out krishna's
links below in the bio all right let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions what is your current
take on the state of our world yeah so
I'm not sure where how did where to go
with that question but what I'll say is
that my current take on the state of the
world is that now more than ever we as
educators at a place like MIT have both
responsibility and an opportunity to
make the world a better place via
education and so when you say state of
the world I I think about how we can
make the world better and and and for us
that comes through education and we now
have the opportunity to think about
education not just of our own students
at MIT which always for us comes first
but to think about education much more
broadly and really globally
we'll come to that later in this
responsibility that you speak of such an
eloquent way to describe it it's these
you know multi ten plus billion dollar
endowment universities that have their
put potential to open up an open source
a lot of the materials and yet repeat
them around the world yeah I mean we can
talk much more about this later but I
think of it as sort of what what we are
doing an open learning is during MIT
inside out
and but we can we can come back to that
a little bit later that's a great
analogy for it yeah yeah so ok let's get
into the journey so Krishna who were you
as a kid worried how did you how did you
get the interest in physics and in even
challenging yourself to come into the
MIT system so I I grew up in Toronto
Canada I was actually born in Germany my
dad's from India my mother was from
Germany they met as students in England
and then my dad finished his PhD and
took a postdoc in Munich where my mother
was and so I was born in Munich so I've
actually liked to say I'm one of the
Bavarian rajagopal they're not too many
of us so I was born in Munich but we
moved to Toronto in Canada when I was
less than a year old so all my growing
up is Toronto I'm I'm Canadian of
whatever played hockey I went to public
schools in suburban Toronto I would say
my I've been interested in physics
really since pretty early on at the
level of reading popular books Carl
Sagan and the popular science books of
that day I was a high school student in
the early 80s suburban North Toronto
North York in fact but my high school
physics teachers were the opposite of
inspiring and actually I would say my
really formative experience in terms of
an educator in my room
and to my credit a lot of what I did
later is my high school biology teacher
I had a tremendous biology teacher in
high school who brought the discoveries
of recombinant DNA and the beginnings of
the the Elector biology revolution
brought them into a public school
classroom in a way that was inspiring so
I actually went to Queens University
arrived there in 84 I went there playing
to major in biology and I think that if
I had gotten to Queens University and my
bio 101 class had been the class that
Eric Lander now teaches at MIT and that
we have an online version of I would be
a biologist today instead I got to
Queens and the biology course that I
took in my first year was felt like I
was just being asked to memorize lots of
stuff and I had a tremendous first year
physics class taught by dr. Chau on my
bow ginger was that mr. Reynolds Dennis
Reynolds and dr. Chows physics class you
could you could ask you could just keep
asking why right you you you if asking
questions was encouraged and there was a
sense that if you asked in a physics
class if you asked why there either be
an answer or if there wasn't an answer
it'd be really interesting and and you
know this was just freshman physics but
the way he taught it was you had a sense
that you were on the beginning of a
journey of exploration of discovery and
and that really I think torqued me back
from biology to physics and you know
I've been physicists really since
undergrad days I would say I had several
really great undergrad research
opportunities in Canada and then I went
to Princeton and did my PhD just where I
got interested in quarks and in fact all
right although not in a way that I'll
describe now because we understood much
less back then but I was already back
then interested in the physics a very
hot quark matter and and the the stuff
that filled the very early universe
although we knew much less so I won't I
won't go back and talk about exactly the
things I was doing back then but I've
been interested in that other other
physics topics also but really since
then and then when fried oh how much you
want to linger on Harvard and Caltech
but
three years as a postdoc at Harvard ph.d
and Princeton and then I was a year at
Caltech and then I joined the faculty at
MIT in 97 I've been physics professor at
MIT for 22 years yeah Dean for digital
learning for a little less than two
years so I want to also understand when
you were younger and you're first
getting to really taste what science the
biology and the physics and the your
fascination with that what did it unlock
for you that made you dedicate the next
even 10 years of your life to it it was
a sense of discovery and understanding
understanding how the natural world
worked playing up playing a role and
sort of in in uncovering the next layers
of understanding you know I one of the
things that so I I don't do this in a
you know in a big sense but I've gone
into schools typically my kids schools
I've got into my kids classes my kids
are now 14 and 16 but as they were
growing up you know every year I would
go into their elementary school or
middle school classes and one of the
things I like to say when I was talking
with the little kids was I can't have to
remember how to set it up but I would I
would I would you know spent half an
hour with them and we were we've done
some some stuff gee-whiz stuff I would
have brought liquid nitrogen or
electromagnets or we and and I would
have gotten them asking me questions as
we've had it and then I would say if you
if you want to
I would always that's right I remember
how he'd set up I would always try to
include something that was not
understood mm-hmm
as opposed to things where I was showing
them how things worked I would always
try to find something like and that I
could describe to them that wasn't
understood and I would say maybe you'll
be the ones who will discover how this
works and and then I would say that if
you want to be a scientist and if you
want to try to figure stuff like that
out you you today have a big advantage
over
most scientists way what's your
advantage and I would let them think
about it and the advantages that they
just ask questions right and so what I
would tell them is it if you want to be
a scientist don't stop asking questions
so that's my that's my pitch to today to
that to the really little kids is just
you know little kids they're natural
they're they're just they just keep
asking why it's just just what they do
and if you want to be a scientist you
just have to keep doing that yeah that's
a cool perspective that when children
come into the world they're natural
scientists and then somehow the culture
and society at large somehow just you
just mold some since some ways as molds
them into just workers rather than the
continuous probing of the universe of
these questions and how things work with
these questions and then I also really
appreciated how you took the initiative
yourself with your kids to go into the
classroom yeah you set up the
experiments with the with the tiny bit
of I don't know how to do that either
yeah if you want to learn how to do that
pursue science yeah if you want to learn
how to do things that science and
society doesn't know go into Sciences
yeah so one of the things I would do
with again I just you know bring liquid
nitrogen you know play with balloons
play with bananas play with roses but
then I would also have a high
temperature superconductor which floats
on a magnet get them all gather around
you can see the little magnet floating
on this sort of hockey puck of
high-temperature superconductor which is
in the liquid nitrogen you can see it
floating there and then I would say so
what do you think the electrons in there
are doing to make it float on that you
know to make that magnet float on what
do you think the electrons in that and
black stuff are doing and the kids would
try to answer in other as well nobody
actually really knows people have mean
people know a lot more than you know
people know more than nothing but nobody
truly understands how that works people
understand how low-temperature
superconductors work but people don't
have a full understanding of how to type
right
so that was one of my things that I
would bring in and it all again kind of
like you said star starts with your
desire to understand that natural world
and how it works yes and that seems to
be a reoccurring theme of a lot of the
people that we sit down with that
insatiable curiosity
probing the universe with that
scientific hypothesizing and and
learning alright let's go into all right
this is a very complicated field we've
had several shows under trying to unpack
particle physics it's not it's not easy
to wrap our minds around so I think what
we can do is we can start with the
notion that atoms make up everything yep
and that atoms have protons and neutrons
in the nucleus
yeah and electrons orbiting yep that
good okay
then this is where things get a little
strange is that the protons and neutrons
on the inside of the nucleus are made up
of quarks yep why is that strange
because now it's just it's just right
for all we know the quarks are made up
of something on the inside of the quarks
it's just we haven't nobodies built a
powerful enough microscope yet to see
the to see any structure inside the
quarks or electrons so as far as we now
know quarks and electrons are the
elementary featureless indivisible
components of the world of the world
that were made of right so the quarks
are assembled into protons and neutrons
the protons and neutrons make nuclei the
nuclei have electrons around them so
it's all electrons and quarks but you
know that's just what we know based on
the microscopes we've been able to build
if we could if we could study the
properties of matter with a thousand
times finer resolution microscope who
knows what we would find but at the
moment I don't think works are any
harder to understand than electrons okay
so now you know double-click us a little
bit deeper into your fascination with
quarks and also how that relates the
first parts of the Big Bang and the soup
of quarks that was there good
so we cyan't we've understood really
since the 1970s that if you get to a
high enough temperature protons and
neutrons shouldn't exist
that the at high enough temperature the
protons and neutrons will be bumping
into each other and smashing smashing
into each other enough you know in a
really high temperature system so that
they just have to fall apart into quarks
okay that's that's been known at a
theoretical level since the 70s really
since quarks were understood and so
we've also known even for even longer
that the universe began with a hot Big
Bang there's now a TV show that confirms
this fact and and so if you go back to
early enough in the universe the
universe was that hot was hot enough
that there were no protons there were no
neutrons so this has been at a
qualitative level like we're talking
here this has been understood really
since the 70s the first papers about the
quarks in the early universe are from
the 70s but do we know where the quarks
came from and well that's the question
of what what happened before the Big
Bang and the answer's no we don't pick
no okay but so what's what's new in the
last 10 or 15 years is that we now have
the ability to actually make a little
droplet of stuff in a matter in the lab
which is that hot it turns out you need
temperatures of a few trillion degrees
trillions of trillions of degrees that's
not the it's not the the better way of
thinking about it is you need
temperatures that correspond to the
energies associated with the motions of
quarks inside of a proton and Wow and
those energies are in the hundreds of MV
so mega electron volts but you turn it
in to a temperature it's it's a few
trillion 10 trillion degrees so how do
you make a droplet of stuff that's 10
trillion degrees hot you build an
accelerator like the Large Hadron
Collider at CERN in Geneva or in fact
these experiments were first done at the
relativistic heavy ion collider Rick
which is in Brookhaven Long Island not
that far from here and you take two
nuclei and and smash them together very
simple I mean it's an extraordinary
piece of technology to do this at the
required energies but you take two
nuclei slam them together at high enough
energies and you will create a little
blob of stuff which is 10 trillion
degrees huh if you if you can make a
stronger powerful and effects re or you
can make 10 trillion degree hot matter
not a whole roomful not a whole
Universal but you know one nucleus size
full okay and that that gets through
that strong nuclear force that's
normally repelling them actually this it
they it has to overcome the
electromagnetic force they're positively
charged but you these are at such high
energies that you can they just slam
into each other and you make the nuclear
force is in fact attractive once you've
got closer once you get close enough
right and then that will turn to
trillions of degrees yeah it's it's it's
just it's just you're creating lots of
entropy it's not it's it's it's just
it's a collision right you you slam two
Swiss watches together they break apart
into their components instead of Swiss
watches you know if you if you sent if
you you know collide to select collide
to Swiss watches at 100 miles an hour
right you're gonna get a pile of screws
and string and Springs you collide two
nuclei at 99.99999 a lot of nines times
the speed of light you're gonna get pile
of quarks percent of the speed of light
yeah and and then you get a lot of
quarks and is that that's the process
where we discovered also the Higgs boson
a similar process goes on in principle
you make things bosons in these
collisions but you'll be very hard to
find them so for Higgs bosons you
collide protons okay
you soli protons or or you could call if
you could had to get enough energy you
could collide electrons and make Hague's
bosons although that's there are there
are reasons why protons are a better
choice but anyway do we do any electron
collisions right now yeah okay we do at
a place called
Jefferson Lab in Virginia but at much
lower energies we had a facility at the
Stanford called the Stanford Linear
Accelerator which did electron
collisions and there is a lot of
discussion in the in the physics
community of building a new higher
energy electron Collider but that that's
for the future but so what I wanted to
say is that
these so you everyone understood that a
high enough energies you could recreate
this stuff of the Big Bang okay
and everyone was right about that but
they were wrong about the following so
before the experiments were done the
expectation was that when you collide
two nuclei at sufficient energies you
would free the quarks the protons and
neutrons would fall apart you'd free the
quarks and there was an expectation that
the quarks that would would form a gas
basically a very hot gas you know ten
trillion degrees it's gonna be a gas
that there were better arguments for
this than that but the expectation was
you're gonna form a gas of quarks quarks
are charged and so a gas of quarks is a
plasma and so this this stuff was named
before it was made okay was called
quark-gluon plasma quarks are quarks
gluons are the particles that bind the
quarks together so you the idea was you
would have a plasma sort of a tenuous
plasma of quarks and gluons which we can
we can leave out and that turned out to
be not quite correct with half correct
and so what we learn so these
experiments started in the year 2000 and
what we understood from the experiments
by about 2005 so since 2005 we've known
that when you make this stuff of the Big
Bang it turns out to actually be a
liquid so in a way that can be made
precise yes you you you destroy the
protons and neutrons and you make lots
of quarks that are not bound up into
individual protons and neutrons but
they're also not free yeah they don't
fly long distances like in a gas they're
always bumping into each other okay so
it's much more like a liquid so so when
I you know we're having a long
conversation but if if we sit down on a
plane and somebody asked me so what do
you do I say I study hot quark soup okay
and and that is a much better name than
quark gluon plasma because every word in
it is correct it's very very hot made of
quark and it's it's like a soup it's a
liquid every it's you know everything
it's not gaseous
it's it's an incredibly hot liquid it
turns out to be a very interesting
liquid with interesting properties and
but I if you'll permit me I'll I'll tell
a story please so in some time in the
late 60s or maybe was early seventies
predecessor at MIT named Vicky by scoff
the great theoretical physicist from a
previous generation when I arrived at
MIT in 1997 Vicky was long retired he
was still present he was very late in
his life I met him very near the end of
his life long after he had retired but
so that was 97 sometime in the 60s or
70s he was giving an after-dinner speech
okay
and his the speech was on the occasion
of the 60th birthday of Edward Purcell
colleague at Harvard and Purcell had
done some great work on fluid flow
hydrodynamics and Vicki wanted to honor
him and so he gave this speech it's a
magnificent speech and one of the things
he said was to honor Purcell for his
work on fluid flow as he said I think if
you take a group of the best theoretical
physicists in the world and you put them
on a desert island and you give them the
laws of quantum electrodynamics how
electrons interact with nuclei you know
you give them the the laws of nature
that describe electrons and nuclei and
ask what do these laws describe so Vicki
said I think that a good student could
have figured out that they describe
atoms you take one of these nuclei you
put electrons around it and it describes
atoms anyone who had learned quantum
mechanics could probably have figured
that out from the laws and a really good
theoretical physicist and sorry a night
student could then I realize that gases
exist because what's a gas it's just a
bunch of atoms flying around it and a
really really good theoretical physicist
could have actually figured out that
solids are a possibility that these laws
of nature describe solids
but he said I don't think any
theoretical physicist given the laws of
nature could have predicted that liquids
exist mm-hmm
he said liquids are much too hard to
understand you know it takes an Edward
Purcell to understand liquids liquids
solids are what happens when all the
atoms just stop moving gases are what
happens when all the atoms are flying
around but who could have predicted
liquid a so he gave this after-dinner
speech and so Vicki was right because
Nature gave not on a desert island but
Nature gave all the theoretical
physicists on the planet Earth the
fundamental laws of how quarks interact
those were discovered in 1973 so every
theoretical physicist on the planet has
known the laws of nature as they apply
to quark since 1973 and we had until the
year 2000 because nobody did these
nobody reproduced this stuff until the
year 2000 everyone thought it was a gas
and then in the 2000 the experiments
were done it turned out to be a liquid
so all the theoretical physicists on the
planet Earth had had 30 years to work on
it and not nobody predicted that quarks
could be a liquid at these temperatures
it was a great discovery from the early
2000s and what I do now is really to ask
well how how can these fundamental laws
of nature that we can write down on a
sheet of paper how do they describe a
liquid where does that liquid come from
what are its properties if you could
study it with a microscope what would
you see what's its phase diagram how
does it does it doesn't are there are
there other phases of quark matter and a
way of saying why this is interesting so
the quick again you're personally in on
the airport the quickest answer is how
cool is it that we can recreate the
stuff of the Big Bang make a little
droplet of Big Bang matter and study its
properties right that's the quickest but
that's actually to me not the most
profound answer to why this is
interesting for me this it it so if you
think about the great quests of physics
there's thinking about the very big so
thinking about stars galaxies is Cosmo
the Big Bang was thinking about their
very small atom you know as you started
this off matters made of atoms atoms
made of nuclei nuclear made of protons
protons have quarks in them what's the
smallest structure so those are those
are two of the sort of big frontiers of
physics and always happen but there's a
third and the third is how do you
complex materials come out of simple
laws okay
the laws of nature can be written on a
t-shirt you've got the wrong t-shirt but
they have some of the beautiful complex
laws of nature the laws of nature can be
written on a t-shirt yeah and and yet
those laws describe solids liquids gases
they describe magnets they describe
superconductors they describe
ferromagnets they describe
antiferromagnets they describe high
temperature super conductivity they
describe wood they describe metal they
describe glass they describe life so how
does complexity come from simple laws
and and that's to me the third great
frontier of physics and we're this hot
quark soup comes in it is I think in a
real sense it is the simplest complex
matter there is okay it's the it's
certainly the first it is the first
complex form of matter that formed in
the universe the universe was a
microsecond old when this stuff filled
it and there it's it was the earliest
complex form of matter and and it is
also in a sense that's hard to make
precise it's the form of complex matter
that is closest to the fundamentals
that's that's not a precise notion but I
but I feel that it's the case and so I
think our challenge is to understand how
these laws describe this matter and I
think if we learn how to do that that
could help us understand how how
fundamental laws describe other forms of
complex matter so to me this this quest
that I'm a part of it relates to
thinking about the early universe that's
the very big it relates to thinking
about the microscopic structure that's
the very small but it most of all
relates to asking the question of how
does how do how does a complex world
come out of simple laws and and that I
think is the most profound answer to why
this is worth doing yeah there's a lot
to be able to figure out about that
process that you're talking about how
does this complex world we live and come
out of such simple laws from yeah Big
Bang until 13.8 billion years later a
civilization on a rock orbiting a star
and all of the complexity of the laws
that have now evolved from us our
complex world as well that's too hard
for me
this is yeah and we're not even talking
about how the brains inside of us are
interacting all a billion of us also too
hard for me yeah this is all extremely
interesting for the kids that we can
inspire to tackle these challenges and
out and oh this is a good segue and said
the question I want to ask you about
what are you teaching right now what are
the kids learning right now in the
physics classes what are they trying to
probe about physics to give us a better
understanding of our world well I have I
have PhD students right now who you know
a PhD student that's it's a very much an
apprenticeship mode of learning so I
would say I would say we are working
together to understand exactly what
we've just been discussing if you ask
sort of more broadly you know we have I
think the world's best physics
department here at MIT and we have great
strengths across the board I think the
biggest development in physics in the
last couple of years is the discovery of
the gravitational waves from two black
holes in spiraling into each other and
colliding you know that piece of
apparatus called LIGO which made that
discovery that was the conceit conceived
by Ray Weiss here at MIT and at the in
the late 60s ray and his colleagues
you know I've done it have done a
remarkable made a remarkable
contribution to our understanding of the
universe by allowing us to hear those
gravitational waves for the first time
and that you know that kind that flows
into what we teach our students we have
a sophomore level class where you get an
introduction to relativity and then we
have a class that is taken by many of
our juniors and seniors although it's
called a graduate class a lot of our
juniors and seniors taken where you
learn general relativity for real and
certainly in that second class but to
some degree in the first you get a sense
of the science behind gravitational
waves that's an example of something
that that we teach right now we have a
great quantum mechanics sequence one of
the few universities with a three-course
undergraduate quantum mechanics sequence
and then you can follow that up by
taking two or three different classes on
quantum information which is another
frontier direction that you know there's
a lot of a lot of excitement and
activity as people are both trying to
build a quantum computer and trying to
understand if somebody built a quantum
computer what could it do and trying to
understand what this teaches us about
quantum information in many other
contexts that also that that's another
example I could keep going we've got I
won't say we do everything because we
don't but but we have you know a big
enough department if it's about 70
physics faculty at MIT out of the
thousand faculty at MIT we have if you
look at our undergrads we have 1,100
undergrads per year about 80 or 90 of
whom major in physics that makes physics
the 4th largest major at MIT so we have
a big impact on the world by teaching
both undergraduates and PhD students I
think we're the not sure if this this I
think we are either either the largest
or very close to the largest department
in the United States I won't say for the
world because I'm not sure in terms of
number of PhDs that we the number of
students who complete a PhD in our
department so we have people doing all
kinds of amazing things whether its
gravitational waves quark-gluon plasma
quantum information biophysics you know
cold atoms you know it's the kind of
place where you sit down with your
colleagues at lunch and some and and and
and you sit down with a colleague who
you haven't seen in a year and there's
something cool they've done in their
group or in their lab that they tell you
and so you want to have something to
tell them you know it's it's a place
where people are making discoveries and
where that's just that's that's just
that's just what we do and it rubs off
on the students and the potential that
we have with more students getting
involved in physics are things like
being able to have an abundant source of
energy through nuclear fusion we have
something like quantum computing which
can run the super intelligences that we
plan on on building so this is extremely
pressing for us so a fusion I want to
give credit to another so we have a
nuclear science and engineering
department at MIT and by the way one of
the things about MIT 8,000 faculty 70 in
the physics department this is an
out-of-date number but about 10 years
ago one of my colleagues got you know
the the listing of all 1,000 MIT faculty
as as as as we were back then and
counted the number of MIT professors who
had a degree in physics who were not in
the physics department and at that time
they're 115 so there are actually more
MIT professors with degrees in physics
outside the physics department and
inside it so physics is everywhere at
MIT yeah
well it's in many places and including
in nuclear science and engineering
so you mentioned fusion that is physics
for sure at MIT it's in our nuclear
science and engineering department and
they have your two spark s Parc teach me
what that is so you should get someone
to come talk with you about spark so the
world has this huge project called eat
era which is being aa
eater so so yeah spark is gonna clean he
tears clogged what so so so hopefully so
eat air is being built in France it has
major US participation but there's lots
of countries involved its the idea is
that it's going to be the first fusion
device that produces more energy than it
takes to run it so it will be a net
producer of energy for the first time oh
is spark at the engine now it's maybe
it's part of the engine it's part I
think it might be okay okay Clint but
okay eat air twenty billion dollars been
spent on it so far many more tens of
billions yet to be spent it's good if
taking 20 years at least to build
nope we don't we hopefully hope it'll
work but it's still a long way away it
it's like 60 or 70 meters tall or in
diameter it's it's big in every sense
it's it's big in size it's big in
complexity it's big an expense it's big
in time duration and so our friends here
at MIT decided to ask well could can we
with modern technology build a smaller
token yes yes okay
so spark is it's only 2 meters instead
of 60 meters roughly I don't know the
that's the scale of it roughly and
tokamak is the is the cutting edge
nuclear fusion technology yeah and it's
you need them you need a magnetic field
to convert can find that hot plasma and
there the idea of the people building
designing and hopefully building spark
is to use much stronger magnets
interests and so you can confine this
plasma and a much smaller volume if you
have much stronger magnets and I think
the physics is completely sound the
engineering is a real challenge here but
they basically so that our nuclear
science and engineering department our
colleagues in that department are
basically trying to make an end run
around eater
they're trying to build a smaller faster
cheaper hotter tokamak that'll achieve
the goals of eat air before eat air is
ever finished so this is a good place to
come a few interest in the fusion also
yes yes
all right let's do some of our our
digital
turning our open learning so you ended
up as you were associate head of the
Department of Physics you ended up
having an MIT X freshman physics course
in junior lab and then a MOOC on quantum
mechanics and quantum field theory so
that's kind of your transition into the
right returning I I helped my colleagues
build all the things you just said yes
yeah I wasn't yeah so basically when I
was associated at physics this world of
digital learning was just beginning
Sanjay was our pioneer here at MIT I was
associated in physics I I worked with
Sanjay to pull together the resources to
find the people to do all the things
that you just said I was the you know we
work together I was the person from the
physics side he was the person on the
digital learning side and we did a bunch
of cool things and now I'm I'm here
trying to do those same kind of cool
things but across MIT as dean for
digital learning but the way I got into
this was as you said and then what was
you know you really you there was likely
a profound realization when the subjects
that back in the time that you were
going through the process of education
like you started saying at the very
beginning of the show you turned it
inside out me accessible globally and
you were like wow we're recruiting yeah
hundred thousand students or more into
so one way of saying this is that when
you know so I was doing very well as a
professor of physics at MIT thank you
very much
now sanjay comes and starts asking me
whether i would like to put a lot of
time and effort into being dean for
digital learning which is now my
principal responsibility how did he
twist my arm into doing that right i
physics is fun
as we've been discussing how did he just
my arm into becoming becoming a Dean and
and i think about this through my kids
and my father so the the my personal
motivations and their their different I
have to explain so when I say my kids my
kids are 14 and 16 now they're they're
younger than MIT
but I know very well how my kids learn
she's from watching them as a parent and
I also pay a lot of attention to how our
undergrads learn and what I see is that
18 and 20 year olds at MIT or 14 and 16
year olds in my home they read books
they read books if the English class
they wanted says read Wuthering Heights
they read a book you know they read
novels they read you know the biography
of Julian Edelman you know they read
books but when they're learning
something like math or chemistry or
physics or you know learning about
nuclear fusion or learning about toe
cracks any of the things we were talking
when they're learning about science or
engineering they don't read books they
they don't when I learned quantum
mechanics I had a book and I over the
course of a semester with a teacher I
started at the beginning of the book I
worked my way through it that's not how
it works anymore because that's not how
you learn when you're 14 and 16 anymore
my kids and our students learn in a very
hyperlinked way mm-hm
okay and they learn from video they
learn online and so part of the drive is
thinking about how we teach at MIT how
do we teach our students the students of
today not it's not me teaching the
krsnah of 1980 where I was an undergrad
in 84 it's not me teaching the Christian
of 1984
it's me teaching the students of 2019
yeah okay and they don't like to sit for
60 minutes and listen to me at the front
talk mm-hmm and this is not a criticism
of me and it's not a criticism of the
students it's because they've realized
that there's a better way to learn yes
okay and we've realized that there's a
better way to teach the kind of material
that you could teach in a lecture it's
better to break it up into five six
seven minute video segments put some
active learning in between some some
some some questions and answers in
between the next segments to make
sequences of
videos and then to you know add online
problems which give you instant feedback
you know when I was a student and until
recently you you you're at MIT or Queens
University where I was a student you do
a promo set yeah yeah right on pencil on
the paper page you hand it in ten days
later you get it back and it's grated
you never look at it that feedbacks
instant now the feedback now is in so so
part of the motivation for me is was
realizing that with these tools we can
teach MIT students better and big and I
and the way I think about that is is by
looking at how my kids and our students
learn okay so that's where my kids come
in is thinking about how they learn and
how you how they can learn better and so
then once you have students at MIT doing
this this kind of online work then in
the classroom you have hands-on
problem-solving experiences you have lab
work you have undergraduate research you
have maker spaces you have projects you
have collaboration you have
team-building you have all kinds of
things that are what make MIT MIT but
you can you can free up more of the
in-class in-person time for all of that
by using these digital learning tools to
to teach Maxwell's equations online so
that that's part of the motivation and
then the other part that my father so my
father can't quick write before we get
to dad yeah it's just that when you're
explaining the difference in the last
let's say forty years and what we're
doing now with education it also is
starting to as we're starting a map
neural activity we can really try to
dive into what's happening in the brain
of people when they're learning this way
and so we now have we know a lot more
from cognitive science and we know that
it's it's it's you know you shouldn't
make the videos longer than about eight
minutes and here we are making out
one-hour video by the way and and it
depends sometimes people go for long
form new
interview content as well we're seeing
it really does depend on exactly what is
trying to happen in that time for you
like for example the fact that we're
talking yeah what makes this okay
actually is the fact that we're talking
to each other okay
there's no point there's no time during
this interview when I lecture you for
more than a couple minutes supplemented
right and but so dialogue dialectic yes
yeah and we're hitting the tennis ball
back and forth right learning more about
you about what you're building yes am i
worth of it anyway also learning in in
problem-solving learning the importance
of retrieval and repetition sort of
laying it down layer by layer all of
this is informed by what we've learned
from modern cognitive science so it's a
part of the motivation for me in doing
digital learning is is helping MIT
faculty to learn how to build and use
the tools that allow us to teach our
students at on my team better and so the
drive for that is is is as I've
described but then the other half is we
have an incredible opportunity to reach
the world now and so I my I don't think
of my when I say my father I'm not
thinking my father of as he is today I'm
thinking my father in 1950 my dad
graduated from Loyola College in what
was then Madras in India in 1950 as a
math major a first class honours degree
in mathematics from Loyola College 1950
and and at that moment in India his
opportunities for further professional
advancement were quite limited and what
he ended up doing was he taught for
eight years at a small college called
oligopoly in Carey Cody because that was
the job that he could get and it was
only through a certain set of lucky
circumstances you know some grits some
initiative some luck that ten years
later he got a scholarship that took him
to Cambridge England where he did a PhD
and and from there
he ended up you know he met my mother I
was born but that's on the side he ended
up getting a job as a faculty member at
York University in Toronto but you know
at that
in 1950 didn't have for someone who with
the really good math he didn't have the
opportunity to take the next step and I
think that that repeats all over the
world today at many many levels but they
could be anywhere on the planet doesn't
have to be India could be Cleveland
could be Cambridge Massachusetts for
that matter could be a 14 year old who
who needs who needs that little extra
something could be a person you know
graduating from from college who needs
to help taking the next step could be
someone who's working in there you know
who's 30 years old who's working and who
needs that needs to go back and pick up
that new skill all of those things were
much much harder to deliver but but now
with these online courses that we can
build we can build online courses that
address all those needs whether it's for
professionals learning supply chain
management or data science whether it's
for kids learning about philosophy we
have a court an online course on a and
philosophy aimed at high school students
whether it's for undergraduates wanting
to learn about quantum information and
quantum computing which they can learn
from us in it go much deeper than you
can get from most other universities
there are so many ways in which we can
add to the education of people all
around the world including people like
my father in nineteen fifty and and so
that's the other motivation it's using
these tools to share mi t--'s
perspective mi t--'s understanding mi
t--'s vision my T's knowledge in a way
that will empower people whom I will
never meet to change the world and it's
it's I think a really powerful vision
which is a real achievable goal you know
where we are right now we have
MIT we've built more than 150 online
courses but we were far from done you
know all the ones I mentioned we built
but I told you we have why no linguistic
course right we have we actually have
three philosophy classes but why no
linguistics course well we just haven't
the faculty member interested in doing
that it just hasn't happened yet except
for the fact that now it's under
construction I have two colleagues who
are building a linguist injured
linguistics course why no cognitive
science class we just haven't gotten to
that one yet but actually we have a
faculty member building the intro to
cognitive science class so so there's I
could within physics I could tell you
what we have and what we don't have and
what we're playing you know so so we're
trying to build out sort of a suite of
online courses that represent sort of
the best that we can offer some of them
are undergrad level some of them are
master's level a few PhD level including
one of our very first actually and you
know I'm very proud of what we've done
but we have a lot more to do and so
that's that's a powerful motivation yeah
and this is so wide-ranging and everyone
you can check out the links below to the
MIT X also to the micro masters program
the OpenCourseWare program and so this
is really it's it's building super
highways to the knowledge right and then
in needs of my responsibility sustained
OpenCourseWare MITx micro masters and
everything we do to support MIT faculty
to teach better on campus that's my job
description and it keeps me busy
definitely and the ability to create the
superhighway like MIT is doing enables
the full flourishing as in the as in the
shirt we see that the seed gets to grow
and have lots of fruits yes for the
world and that's because it got the
proper nutrients in the soil systems and
that's the super highways of knowledge
the basic love water food compassion the
basic things shelter that that seeds
need to do so now electricity and
Internet and computers to get the
connection to the superhighway also just
another thing for everyone to know is
that these specific phenomenons that
you're embedding into all of the mi
t--'s digital learning are you know
these closed-loop feedback so you're
getting it right
way when we when we when we gain the
ability to do so with simulation we will
embed a quick bit of what did krishna
just teach about physics and then
they'll get to address that show so you
you can if you want to think about doing
that the edx platform which on which we
put all of our online courses it's open
source so you can create your own
instance your own open edx platform in
which you you could start doing exactly
what you just said that's beautiful so
simulation will have to get to that
point where you know scaling things up
building teams to be able to do so and
we care a lot about being able to embed
things like that that's excellent cuz
that's going to help with the retention
of the knowledge and also the fact that
it's open through EDX is so crucial and
then also for the closed loop and also
another thing is just this phenomenon of
things like balloon to Sigma to be able
to have a mentor that you can work with
on a desert uder a one-on-one basis that
helps you perform so much better than
those that are just in a 30 person class
with an individual teacher so we can you
know we can do a lot better on that
still we have a discussion forum in all
of our MOOCs but it's that's not a
one-on-one mentor yeah we have a
discussion forum in which questions are
answered by you know a real person from
MIT that's that's I think a really great
thing that we're offering but it's not
one-on-one mentoring what our Dean is
doing with the boot camps gets a little
closer yeah so you met with our Dean
earlier so so the boot camps that our
Dean is is is creating include a lot of
coaching which is which which comes much
closer to that one-on-one mentoring you
know and though but the way I think
about it with our MOOCs is that
crucially it could be as simple as just
pairing someone that's studying physics
MOOC to someone else in that community
that's already in in your industry in
physics so we wonder can we use can we
employ MIT alumni in this way I don't I
don't mean employing a little bit can we
engage MIT location
can we engage MIT alumni in this way we
have people who took the MOOC last year
who stay in the MOOC this year and play
that role we call them community TAS and
they just volunteer they just do that
because they want to but what I was
really gonna say is that I think what we
can really work hard at doing is to
engage with other educational
institutions up and down the whole
spectrum you know if I think in u.s.
terms community colleges two-year
colleges four-year colleges liberal arts
colleges the whole spectrum because each
of them is filled with educators that
know how to teach their students ok so
we have a great partnership with San
Jose City College which is a community
college in in San Jose and they have
created an educational opportunity for
their students ok it's it's their
teachers doing this for their students
but that opportunity includes some some
initial steps and then there's an MIT
online computer science intro to
computer science class to two classes in
fact from MIT and then there's several
classes online classes from Berkeley so
San Jose City College picked some of our
stuff some of Berkeley stuff they added
and the the the introductory elements
themselves they added internship
opportunities they added the mentoring
they added that and so they put together
an educational opportunity which is it's
better than what they could have done
just by themselves because they use the
MIT content and the Berkeley content but
it's much better than what MIT and
Berkeley we don't we're not skilled at
teaching those students they are right
now and so we put out content that they
can use to make the education of their
students better and that's what I love
that model it's in soo I want to see
more and more institutions asking given
the set of things that are out there
online including what we offer but the
whole world of online education giving
the set of things that are out there how
can we use those online opportunities to
make the education of our students whom
whose abilities we know how can we make
their education better and we're talking
with lots of institutions
in this mode it's been such a great
conversation I have a couple quick
questions on the way out the first
question is what would you say is one of
the most crucial skills for young people
and even adults to be developing going
into the exponential technology age so
I'll surprise you with my answer but
I'll this is the answer that I'd give it
to many people including my kids if I
think back so I'm a professor of physics
and what I do is very mathematical and
there's there's science that through and
through and if you ask me what did I
learn in high school that has been of
the things I learned in high school
what's the most important to my career
what's your puts the answer curiosity I
learned that long before high school
okay
critical thinking questioning that that
those are all important but it was how
to write oh wow
I write reasonably well I'm not a I
don't write as well as the great writers
of the world but I write well and and
that's been incredibly important to my
career too it's it's you know you got to
apply for grants you got to write papers
you've got to write you know one-pagers
that persuade your department head or
Dean of something and I didn't I learned
to write in high school you know I
learned math and physics in high school
yes it's true but I learned those much
better later right I learned them over
again I you learn math and physics you
learned them over and if you're become a
professor or physics you learn math and
physics over and over again at higher
and higher levels but I feel that it was
my high school English and history
teachers that taught me how to write and
that's been an incredibly important so
my advice to that to the kids to the
little kids is is curiosity critical
thinking keep asking questions all of
those things and reading and writing you
know and and the foundations of math
which you know so the fundamentals and I
think if you have to build that
foundation at a very young age yes
and then don't lose the curiosity yeah
exactly yeah the roots the roots at a
very young age all right and then are we
in a simulation
I don't think so and why well I have no
idea really that's not that's not course
a question that I don't if it's a good
enough simulation how could we possibly
know right soso you know I don't think
so but I have no evidence I have no
evidence that we are right I know it is
that we are but you know maybe I'm naive
but I think there's a real world out
there um I don't think we're necessarily
but do I really no no I can't say I
really know and then the last question
is what is the most beautiful thing in
the world
oh my goodness
when you're in the high Alps and you've
you know spent a whole day
I don't climb but I hike you spent a
whole day hiking up to one of the the
high huts you know just on the edge of a
glacier at you know you know around
3,000 meters in the Alps and you're
watching the sunset that's that's that's
what occurs to me when you ask that
question every summer we go to the Alps
most often I pair that with spending
time at CERN where the accelerator that
I described is and so I talk with the
scientists there find out the latest
what I you know the the best place to
hear the latest unpublished results in
my field is the cafeteria at CERN and so
I spent time at the cafeteria that
started catching up and then the whole
family we spend time in the Alps and you
know we we know each of the last two
summers we've done something along the
lines of all four of us with an Alpine
guide we we do a hike from the valley
floor up to that Hut at 3,000 meters
that's the strenuous part of the
excursion for me for my kids that's just
a walk and then that afternoon they go
and do some rock climbing with the
Alpine guide and then the next morning
they leave at about 5:00 in the morning
because they're summoning a 4000 meter
peak where the alpinist who name is
Robin he's a great teacher and so they
they traverse a glacier climb a rock
wall summit this four thousand meter
peak and come down the other side to
this other Hut down the other side and
meanwhile my wife and I have done this
wonderful hike you know out this valley
around and up the next Valley to the
other Hut we mean the kids kids there
and then the day three we hike back down
we have done something along those lines
and two different spots in the Alps each
of the last two summers and we're
planning our one for this summer so
these deep immersions into the beauty of
Mother
yeah yes yes Krishna yes thank you so
much for coming on thank you it's been a
pleasure yeah thank you very much thank
you thank you thanks everyone for tuning
in we would love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode
also share more content around physics
share more content around digital
learning with your friends your family
your co-workers online on social media
check out the links in the bio below to
Krishna's work as well as mitx and all
of the other programs go and check it
out and share it support the
organizations the entrepreneurs the
artists around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below help us do it continue doing
cool things like in 2020 hopefully
building a recording studio our second
one in Cambridge as well as our first
one in San Francisco so we can actually
have a physical location in this second
beautiful cluster of intelligent people
and go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon
thank you and thank you thank you and
peace everyone